the Joe Rogan experience and I feel like
what we are doing therein and these
great martial arts teachers that we've
had teach us is how to be sort of almost
like you're fighting this fight mmm
but there's no rage you're not actually
even angry at the person it's actually
just you're just doing what you're
supposed to do right now can I be
completely relaxed and do this under
stress under guys try it guys trying to
choke the life out of you yeah literally
yeah I had that I had you know I had a I
had a fight back then I don't like to
fight I'm not like I don't look at
myself as a fighter I look at myself
more as a meditator I got in a fight
right at that time probably when I saw
you last what happened a guy it was in
Santa Monica guy just stole my car oh
wow it was my first date with my wife is
our first day we've married 16 years
a guy stole my car and how did you catch
him well we are walking up the street
and she said oh you left your lights on
your car and I said now I have a I have
a Saab you need the keys to open on the
to get the lights on so I can't be my
car but my top was down was a
convertible Saab and the top was down
and I was like man that is my car had my
lights on and then I realized there is
this dude in my car trying to start my
car and my wife left her keys in the
glove compartment and I guess he opened
the glove compartment went into a
convertible which was open I had no life
was when it was old Saab 900 I used to
have and you put the keys in and he just
couldn't start because it wasn't the
right keys so I don't I don't know if it
was because of yoga or jiu-jitsu or
whatever it was but I was so calm about
it I just said hold my sweatshirt and I
was super skinny then I was like I don't
remember my diet was I was 100% raw
foodist
vegan like you know a buck 47 soaking
wet with the crystal in my pocket you
know
and I just said in a very calm way just
to hold my jacket and I ran I jumped on
the back of the trunk I jumped over and
jumped on his head and the night and I'm
small so I Drive real close to the
steering wheel and I slipped behind him
and tried to choke him but I couldn't
get deep enough behind him to get the
choke in and it was this big dude I
couldn't really tell from when I jumped
it was a big dude I just said and he
said you trying to choke me I'm gonna
kill you but it was such a stall mate
because he couldn't move I couldn't get
the choke in deep enough and it was just
a stomach and it went on for three
minutes just there whoa but I was just
breathing and then he went back to grab
my face and you do that thing in jujitsu
where you hook the guy's arm with your
leg so he had that I had that arm trap
he couldn't move I couldn't move my wife
was looking at me she's not calling the
cops she's just like looking they're
shocked it's our first date it's
midnight in Santa Monica right that
elections right you know by the coffee
bean or something yeah and finally we
stand up in the seat they're standing
the front seat my windows are up at the
top is down I cup his neck and I punched
him twice
and he grabs me by the shirt he grabbed
him by the shirt and we throw each other
through the windows oh gee and they snap
and shatter we fall out of the car over
the door and roll in the street and I
put him in my guard and then he just at
that point I think he just turned and
ran and I pulled his shirt off check
this out
I had his shoes his cuz fell off they
were sort of like untied adidas his
shoes fell off his pants dropped to his
ankles cuz there were low sagging pants
his baseball hat fell off and he pulled
his shirt and I had a shirt and he ran
away and we're both covered in blood cuz
there's glass all over us and he runs
away in his underwear pulling up his
pants in his socks and that's the story
my wife looks and I was like what you
call the cops she's like I don't know
that was sorry look is the coolest thing
I've ever seen I was like I was the
coolest thing I've ever
I've ever done she's like he could've
had a gun I was like I know I he could
have actually killed me I've never you
know I don't know how I would react
again if that ever happened but that's
just what happened I think it's because
it was sort of like in that mood of this
is my duty I have to protect my car
right and also the other thing is you
are used to like pretty intense conflict
when you joined you just do all the time
and then you don't we do MMA yeah week
yeah and that was some yeah yeah and all
those guys had jean-jacques sorry are
the cops mm-hmm I'd call them cops or
robbers they were see like one of them
well the thing about jujitsu is you do
it full blast right you don't you don't
break arms or actually choke people
unconscious if they tap you let go but
your that trust moment yeah you're going
as hard as you can
that's the difference you're so
accustomed to that so when you're
rolling with this guy also people that
aren't accustomed to that they they feel
vulnerable panic was gonna do feel it
right away they feel awkward they feel
strange yeah like I've rolled the people
that don't know how to roll just joking
around
rolling with people like come on let me
do jujitsu with you let me see what it
feels like they're helpless they're
helpless helpless it's a weird feeling
it's like you look like a normal you
look like my size you know you look like
me and I should be but you're you're
vulnerable you're so vulnerable right
it's just like there's such a big learn
a little earning curve is so sharp it's
so sharp it's so sharp but once you get
to like Bluebell purple belt it's like
that area like a regular person is
really helpless they really are you know
it's you know it's interesting even with
that fight I don't look at myself as a
fighting guy or and I definitely don't
look for fights but it's almost like
you're learning a game you know and then
you realize oh this game is completely
deadly yeah it is a deadly game I mean
this is exactly what it is you're
playing a game I'm trying to kill you
you're trying to kill me but we're
really good friends
that's the crazy thing it's like a lot
of guys who have technically killed me
you know because I have a tab they're my
they're basically good friendly my best
friend yeah they're really nice you know
and I can't wait to try to kill them
again
like it's a very strange thing to
practice but it's very cleansing like
the people's that do it all it's a
therapy yeah they're so peaceful yeah I
don't know if any other I didn't really
study Marsh other martial arts except a
little more Thai in Thailand but um but
I wonder if it you get the same cards
you don't have to pull yeah
you'll have to you know either go light
or you I mean in Thailand if it's like I
went to kick a guy and he blocked it
with his shin you know it lifted his
knee and I got a bruise from my ankle to
my knee that was like yeah it's brutal
its brutal spirit yeah I got mad enough
to condition the [ __ ] out of your shins
I said it takes years to
[Applause]